こんにちはイクシーの近藤と申しますよろしくお願いします
僕はこの義手を作っています
テレビスキッズはですね子供もそして僕みたいな大人も自分がしていることを心置き
なく話して良い歯だと聞いていますので今日は僕が今一番作りたいこの義手について
話したいと思います
では早速
この義手はですね筋肉の動きを読み取って動きます
今僕の左手にセンサーが貼られています
この信号を読み取りまして今僕が
思い通りに動かしています
義手なので手がない方のためのものなんですが手を失った方もては失っても手を動かす
筋肉は残っています
なので同じような仕組みで思い通りに動かすことができるわけです
で慣れていきますと
ちょっと地味ではわかりづらいんですが facebook の陰でマークですね
わかりましたん
こんなことも出来るような義手です
はい
他にもすごいところがありまして
モーターとか電子部品以外はすべて3 d プリンターで作っています
なのでこういう技術はですね実は戦前からあったんですが今市場のものは150万円と
かものすごい高くて1%猫しか使えていないんですね
それをまだ開発段階なんですが材料費だけで3万円程度で作っております
でこの義手の特徴は安さだけではありません
デザインにもこだわっております今回お持ちしたのは黒いタイプなのですが
写真にありますように白いタイプもを作っています
今までの義手というのはですねてがないことを隠すことを目的としていましたので肌色
に似せたデザインしかなかったんです
ですが僕たちはこう考えます我々が日頃つける腕時計やスニーカーのように使う人の
好みに落ちた様々なデザインがあってみる
いいのではないかとそういう思いを込めてこの義手の本セプトは気軽な選択肢という風
に言わせていただいております
この義手を僕ひとりで開発しているわけではなくこのようなメンバーで作っています
一番左がソフトウェアを担当している僕です
その右が
メカ機械とかですね大ターン
開発しています山浦さん一番右がこのカッコイイデザインを考えている
今日さんです
そして右から2人目エバンジェリストと変えていますがこの方がこの義手の1人目の
ユーザになる予定の森かあさんです
この後の僕のスピーチではこの盛りかあさんが主人公となりますのでしっかり名前を
覚えてください
森川さんです
で8少し障害者という言葉について話したいと思います
先ほどから生姜に関するトークが続いていますが僕はこの障害者という言葉は
ものすごい乱暴な言葉だと感じています
あたかもその人に大きな欠陥があるような響きがありますしその人が障害者と呼ばれる
ことによって周りの人も必要以上に距離を置いてしまったり必要以上にかわいそうだと
思ってしまうっているような気がしています
少し自分の話をしますと僕は今から5年前
1年間アメリカに留学していました
楽しい思い出もたくさんあったのですが当然辛い事も色々とありました
まず言葉が完全には通じません
それから様々な生活様式
笑いのツボなども住み慣れた日本とは全く異なるものでした
僕は日本人として生まれそれまで日本で育ってきました
そんな僕がこのアメリカという環境において感じたのはもしかすると自分は障害者かも
しれないというような気持ちでした
当然自分としては自分が障害者であるなんて認識はそれまでなかったですし
認めたくもないわけです
つまり何が言いたいかといいますと障害という言葉は人に対して使うべきではないと
いうことです
障害というものは人にあるのではなくてですね
人と環境が不正後ちょっと環境がしっくりとかみ合わない
そんな状況に対して使うべきではないかと考えています
話をティッシュに戻します
僕たちが今暮らしている環境というのはあらゆるものが両手を持つ人を前提に作られて
います
そんな環境の中でてを1本を失う
コツというのは
人に障害があるのではなく環境とてが1本しかないその人との間に不整合があるそこに
障害があると考えています
8主人公の森かあさんですこちらの写真は森かあさん自身の写真で2年前
事故でてを失われる前の写真です
森かあさんはパラグライダーをを趣味にされていましてそれこそ
平気で300キロ空を飛んでいたようです
こちらの頭は環境と森かあさんの関係を簡単に表したものです
手を失うまでの森かあさんは
それこそ普通の人以上のことをできていましたので当然以上のことができるというよう
な状況にありました
それが
ある日事故でてを失うことによって
当然のことができないという状況に陥ってしまいました
でここで義手の登場なのですが義手でやりたいことは
まず
当然のことをできるような状況にする今だと靴紐を結ぶこともできませんし自転車に
乗ることもできない
料理を作ることができないです
ですがそうではなくてですねここでは止まらずに同時に僕たちはパラグライダー
ライターを乗っていた頃のようにもう一度当然以上のことができる状況にしたいと考え
ています
で最新の動画です
こちらはつい先週ですね森母さんに初めて僕たちの義歯を装着していただいた際の映像
です
最後ペットボトルの映像が流れましたがヘッドバトル開けようとすると
片手だとですね脇に挟んだり股に挟んだりして開けなきゃいけないのでどうしても力が
入りすぎてこぼれてしまうようなことがあるみたいなんですねそれが少しずつで解決し
てきています
そしてへともう一つ映像がありまして
pa
こちらは先週ですねこれも展示会で森かあさん自身でも知った大火災の映像です
多分インターネット星に守りかあさんも今僕の発表を見ていただいているんですが少し
失礼かもしれませんが森かあさんは40過ぎの
浮いてしまえばおっちゃんですそんなをちゃんがこんなみんなが楽手がを求められる
っていうことは僕は当然ではないか明日以降このように
当然なことを
するような芳香ともう一つ当然以上のことをできるような方向で開発していきたいと
考えています
a 棟このデザインに関してもを守りかあさんの希望を取り入れて
開発したのですがそのほかにもさまざまなデザインがあって良いと考えています
例えば一番右のものは小指の関節のあたりが金属になっています
義手だとパーツパーツを変えられますので例えば指輪のような感覚で
デザインすることも可能だとか思います
それから拡張性というのもも立ちたいと考えています
指を交換できるので作業をしたいときはグリップ性の高いものに変えたりスポーツを
するときは蛍光色のようなファッション性の高いものに帰るそれから
最後一番右ですが suica などの ic チップを指に埋め込んで
カード取り出さずに指をかざすだけで改札を通れるようなことも可能になってくると
考えています
最後ですねこのように僕は森かあさんといっしょに偽証を開発しているのですができれ
ば
多くの方と一緒に開発したいと考えています
そうしないと人と環境の不整合というのは解決しないのではないかと
いろいろと仕掛けていこうと考えています一つがオープンソースです
まだ
準備ができていないのですが何僕たちが開発しているこの義手のデータを公開して
世界中の技術を持つ人があ少しずつ改良できるような
あ仕掛けを作っていきたいと考えています
もう一つがクラウドファンディングです
こちらは
えすでに先週から始めているんですが当然
受賞を開発するためにはお金が必要ですそのお金を人口や
当社から集めるのではなくて
少ない額でいいので多くの一般の方から集められないかとを始めました
そしてふたを開けてみるとなんと1週間で100人以上の支援者の方から計100万
以上を資金が集まっております
この場を借りて支援いただいた方には感謝したいと思います
でインパクトとしては当然
金額もあるのですが
100人もの人がこの開発に携わってくれたという事実にとても励まされています
ちなみにこのクラウドファンディングは1月中旬まで続ける予定なのでもしご興味が
あればよろしくお願いします
っていうわけで最後です僕たちはてがないということが障害とならないような世界を
目指して今後この義手の変え実用化に向けて頑張っていこうと上げていますご清聴
ありがとうござ
ありました